cette semaine c'est une semaine un peu
particulière on parlait de courtoisie au
volant pour cette journée mais ça se
poursuit toute la semaine
cette semaine c'est aussi la semaine de
la presse à l'école ça veut dire quoi ça
pour les parents que nous sommes les
grands parents qui nous regardent etc
les enfants connaissent mais moi je
connais pas c'est quoi la semaine de la
mode l'art ni sur la 30e semaine de la
presse et des médias à l'école c'est un
temps un vraiment un temps fort de
l'éducation aux médias l'information
bon il faut dire que dans les
établissements scolaires cette éducation
médias à l'information elles se
déroulent toute l'année puisqu'elle est
intégré au programme mais là c'est un
enfant parce que les médias se sont
engagés à offrir gratuitement des
journaux des accès aux sites web
gratuitement et donc ça permet une
découverte des médias du modèle
médiatique du système médiatique aux
élèves ça c'est un point fort est le
deuxième c'est développer son esprit
critique par des activités qui vont
c'est cette oeuvre qui me semblent
l'éducation aux médias pour nos enfants
et nos petits-enfants ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire que vous leur expliquer par
exemple ce que sont les fausses
informations et les fake news comment on
va rechercher l'information comme on
vérifie forme et cias et c'est notre
travail au quotidien de travailler sur
la fiabilité de l'info de vérifier ses
sources donc on a des tas de dispositifs
mais c'est la fin de l'analyse mais
aussi quand les élèves produisent ils se
rendent compte et c'est ce qu'on va
faire avec le festival de web radio
demain le fait d'être producteurs
d'information on se rend compte delà de
l'exigence que
nécessite ce métier des règles de
vérification de l'information
donc c'est à la fois de la compréhension
mais aussi la production
hier on est toujours sur les deux
aspects alors justement dans le
production j'ai vu quelques images
passées j'ai vu des micros des casques
de radio des ordinateurs voilà on
imaginer une émission de radio c'est ça
le festival web radio de demain
expliquez moi ces lignes alors ce n'est
pas que ça mais c'est effectivement le
moment fort attendu à la fin de la
journée
donc voilà comment ça se passe en fait
le matin les tous les jeunes sont réunis
et ils font une conférence de rédaction
donc cette année nous avons yannick
brière qui est notre invité qui est sur
radio bresse bêtise et donc c'est lui
qui va guider un petit peu nos jeunes
vers des sujets soit d'actualité soit
culturelle soit sportif donc c'est
vraiment des sujets qu'ils auront choisi
eux à partir de ce moment là ils partent
à l' aventure donc effectivement soient
commandés quand même parce qu'on vous
recommande un sujet avec un angle précis
tout à fait c'est tout à fait ça donc
effectivement il ya des notions aussi
qu'ils vont découvrir au cours de cette
journée est donc soit ils partent
commencé leurs recherches ils préparent
des interviews ensuite ils se rendent
dans les lieux pour répondre de
reportages pour répondre à leurs besoins
et à la fin de la journée ils doivent
rendre tous leurs documents si bien
audio que papier et enregistré donc
comme on a vu tout à l'heure
comme on le voit même maintenant
émission de radio tout à fait dans les
conditions du direct qu'elle sera
diffusée ou qui sera diffusé sur la page
facebook de positive radio donc le
l'enregistrement aura lieu de 16 heures
à 17 heures et on m'a confirmé qu'à
partir de 20 heures ce serait disponible
sur le site
ça fait déjà quelques années que ce
festival existe il ya lieu demain il
s'adresse aux enfants de quel âge parce
que j'en vois ceux des prêts à 12,6
alors nous on a des secondes parfois on
a de la seconde à la terminale ces
lycées en règle générale nous ont
privilégié les seconds parce que c'est
une thématique qui est abordée en
français donc c'est vrai que ça rentre
dans le programme totalement c'est un
début de la semaine de la presse à
l'école
oui mais toute cette semaine on va avoir
des tas d'événements des tas d'activités
et donc demain on commence par ce
festival de web radios il faut savoir si
tu les établissements à mettre en place
reçoivent des journalistes des
dessinateurs de presse des photographes
pourra être la rencontre de ceux qui
produisent l'information et puis parler
de ce qui va se passer cette année on le
voit sur la fiche laruns du 18 au 23 mai
la semaine c'est la 30e anniversaire
c'est l'information sans frontières ça
veut dire quoi c'est un thème alors là
on peut le décliner sans frontières
géographiques et c'est vrai que certains
vont aller enquêter interviewé des
personnes qui sont à l'étranger ou qui
sont étrangers qui vivent en france mais
ça peut être des frontières sociales ça
peut être des frontières technologiques
et donc il ya toute une réflexion le mot
sans frontières c'est un point
d'interrogation
est-ce qu'on est tous sur la liste par
exemple grosse question vert avec le
fameux portable a parlé avec clément
guillou
ima n'importe quel ballon sur de la
désinformation du fiqh nous donc on peut
réfléchir à ça voilà est-ce qu'on dit ou
journalistes aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut
être considéré pendant tout journaliste
et donc c'est vrai que cette semaine va
être très riche en événements en
activité c'est un enfant et en
découvertes pour de futures vocations
bien sûr y'a pas de soucis plus
largement en bourgogne franche comté
quel genre d'autres événements proposés
alors je dis par exemple on a un
événement qui concerne les lycéens de
bourgogne et france-comté puisque avec
le conseil régional on organise depuis
plusieurs années un concours de presse
écrite et jeudi c'est la finale les
élèves ont donc nous on a déjà lu leurs
journaux on a trié les meilleurs
journaux et les équipes qui sont
finalistes vont devoir présenter à
l'oral leur travail leur réflexion avec
un par un chaque année on a un parent
qui est un dessinateur de presse cette
année iranien réfugié politique et on
sera à dole très bien au lycée duhamel
alors on va pas faire le catalogue de
tous les événements parce que mieux
c'est d'aller faire un petit tour sur le
site big three du heat les génies pour
en savoir plus ils disent on voit les
médis gens mais quand on va dessus on se
rend compte que c'est beau une franche
comté donc voila sinon il faut quand
même préciser les faits c'est important
imaginez que c'est que dis je n'ai pas
du tout donc si vous voulez en savoir
plus sur toutes les initiatives en cours
vous allez faire un tour sur le site
général du clemi plus large